pride the pleasure of knowing this man
for quite some time because he worked
along with my wife for HBO's real sports
and this man is a cover to record 14
Olympic Games ABC sports CBS NBC sports
now of HBO's sports the fight game with
Jim Lampley and Canelo Alvarez and
triple G we'll be coming back to a
television set near you on September the
15th a couple of Saturday's live on HBO
pay-per-view good to see you Jim landed
to see rich pleasure to be here so this
fight after having done so many fights
Jim where does this one rank for you
well it's the biggest one on the horizon
right now and you know I rise to a high
level of expectation every time we have
a fight of this impact and magnitude
within the sport this is the only fight
that will take place this year between
two of the top five or six names in the
sport they're arguably the two biggest
names in the sport outside of the
heavyweights Anthony Joshua and Deontay
Wilder clearly that fight isn't taking
place this year so this a rematch of
2017 s biggest fight is 28 teams biggest
bike and it's an entirely different kind
of confrontation because of the events
that have taken place in the intervening
12 months last year's fight was a
high-level sports event between two
honorable competitors who actually kind
of liked each other and respected each
other this is an all-out blood feud
between two guys who don't have any use
for each other at all and the level of
animosity on both sides probably will
affect the nature of the combat in the
ring and in unpredictable ways it's hard
to tell who benefits from the higher
level of venom going into the second
fight so the fact that Canelo got popped
for peds right adds what to this measure
yeah well it by by testing positive
twice for performance-enhancing drugs he
managed to kick away the original
scheduled date of May 5 for this rematch
that occasion the need for a third
contract negotiation between the two
fighters teams and that contract
negotiation was far more angry and and
and discordant than that which had
preceded it
it took a last-minute infusion of money
from sources that still aren't a hundred
percent clear to the general public to
get golovkin to agree to terms for the
second fight it got a much bigger bite
of the pie then he got the first time
around and you know once again they
don't like each other they don't like
each other for a riot variety of
different reasons now and that's an
entirely different emotional context
than a year ago what is your stance on
the decision in a split decision draw of
the pelvis flipped decision draw was a
terrible decision I mean I think an
overwhelming majority of the ringside
observers and an overwhelming majority
of the audience as reflected on social
media agreed that Gennady golovkin was
the logical winner of the first fight
but he didn't win the fight in the role
of Gennady golovkin you know he came
into the fight as the most celebrated
pure attacker in the sport and a guy
with a spectacular knockout record he
beat Canelo if you agree that he beat
Canelo and I do with boxing skill and
his jab it wasn't the way he was
supposed to win the fight and and that
may have in some ways left the door open
to the draw decision but you know almost
no responsible observer I know of
believes that a draw was exactly the
right call in the first fight it seemed
clear that gennady won more rounds than
Canelo Jim Lampley here on the Rich
Eisen show and again Saturday September
15th HBO pay-per-view 8:00 p.m. Eastern
and 5:00 Pacific brought to you by HBO
Sports which also brings you the fight
game with Jim Lampley the sport outside
of the sweet science you enjoyed
covering the most would be what Jim
outside of the sweet science the sport I
enjoyed covering the most well I had you
know so many different experiences I
mean you mentioned the 14 Olympics I had
a dozen years of hosting Wimbledon on
HBO and and I love the very thin margins
of
competition in tennis as evidenced once
again last night by Federer's upset loss
at the hands of the what number 55
ranked Blair right in the world that
kind of thing happens more frequently in
tennis than in any other sport and I
really learned to love that when I was
covering it with Arthur Ashe Billie Jean
King Martina Navratilova Mary Carillo we
had an amazing line-up of expert
commentators working with me when we
were doing that I got my start covering
college football at ABC and the 1970s
and I did have several years as the
quote senior reporter for real sports
yeah and I've always liked you know the
graininess of the topical story and
everything so I couldn't really isolate
any one thing I've had a lot of lucky
lucky gigs so what was the first gig you
ever had Jim well for I was chosen from
a nationwide talent hunt in 1974 to go
to work on the college football
sidelines for ABC but the very first
broadcasting gig this was to work on
pregame and postgame radio shows with
football coach bill Dooley and
basketball coach Dean Smith at the
University of North Carolina in Chapel
Hill what was that like with Dean Smith
Jim I learned so many amazing lessons of
life from Dean Smith and there are there
are things he said to me and lessons I
learned from Coach Smith that come up
virtually every day in my life like what
well I'll never forget in 1972 the first
time I ever came to Los Angeles the
final four was here in LA and North
Carolina was heavily favored against a
kind of little-known Florida State team
in one semi-final and UCLA was heavily
favored in the other semi-final against
Louisville and UCLA and and Carolina had
been number one and two all year long
UCLA had Walton Carolina had McAdoo our
question in Chapel Hill was when McAdoo
goes to the top of the key and shoots
rainbow jumpers is Walton going to go
with him and to make a long story short
a tremendous player named bill
Chamberlain who had been the MVP of the
eastern region of the week before was
three or four minutes late to the
pregame
meal at the Century Plaza Hotel and
coach Smith calmly announced to the team
that bill wouldn't play the first half
and the team was psychologically
discombobulated Florida State went up by
21 points in the first half and a second
half comeback fell short and after the
game I realized I was about to have to
ask coach Smith the first difficult
question of my career
so in the interview I asked him I said I
was in the pregame meal I saw that Bill
was three minutes late
this was the national semi-final could
an exception have been made and coach
Smith looked at me blankly and said
tonight was one night we coach every
player for four years and I I think of
that almost every day of my life
seriously that is one day in tonight was
one night we coach every player for four
years that was the end of the subject
you're getting emotional just bringing
this up well I mean I can't think of
Coach Smith without getting emotional
and by the way that puts me in the same
category with all of the players who
played for him Jim Lampley here on the
Rich Eisen show who's the biggest
character the biggest characters who
ever came across well I could cite a
thousand of them but I I spent years
working with George Foreman and and
George Foreman is a larger-than-life
human being with an incredibly complex
mind I mean though people think of
George to a certain degree as a clown
because of the way he built his second
career but George is a brilliant human
being who by the way also taught me some
some life lessons at bad moments in my
career so you know you you say who's the
biggest character clearly there been a
thousand of them right but George comes
to mind the media and so that's covering
and broadcasting with him or what do you
think of um both covering and
broadcasting with him because I believe
George is the most underappreciated
heavyweight of all time for one reason
he won the legitimate heavyweight
championship of the world 20 years apart
has two different fighters and two
entirely different human beings it's not
just one of the greatest accomplishments
in the history of boxing it's one of the
greatest accomplishments in the history
of all sports
and people don't give him enough credit
for the panoramic change that was
necessary for him to become the guy who
won the second fight after losing the
first one to Muhammad Ali do you think
if Larry merchant was fifty years
younger he'd be able to kick Floyd
Mayweather's ass Jim Lampley
well Mayweather is a backup counter
puncher and Larry would be a pure
attacker I love that take your pick
that's one of my favorite oh it's Louis
fiers here's how great that line was
Larry said if I was 50 years younger I'd
kick your ass and that about 8:30 or
quarter to 9:00 Pacific on a Saturday
night
yeah by noon the following day you could
buy t-shirt on the Venice pier with a
picture of Larry's face that says if I
was fifty years younger I'd kick your
ass by noon the following day fewer than
16 hours later you could buy that
t-shirt on the Venice pier and there was
no social media at the time no that's
right but social media I one of the
things I love to say is that no sport is
as dramatically affected by social media
as boxing the entire story of Floyd
Mayweather's career particularly his
epic financial arc is a story of social
media and social media is a huge context
for what will go on in the second fight
between Gennady golovkin and Canelo out
how so walk me through that a lot of the
feud that's taken place since Canelo's
positive drug tests has taken place on
social media both with direct
contributions to social media by people
like golovkin's trainer Abel Sanchez and
also indirect with people tweeting and
sending around quotes that they read
here and there or hear from the two
fighters and the fight game with uh with
Jim Lampley
airing Wednesday at 11:00 p.m. on HBO
new episode available on HBO now HBO Go
HB on demand and partner streaming
services why do you what do you do the
Shoji well the fight game is an
opportunity for me to make a personal
statement about boxing we try to tie it
to big fights so for instance there's
one tomorrow night as you say on HBO and
then there'll be another episode that
will air September 19
four days after the fight and I'm the
executive producer the show I'm the
writer of the show
I'm the talking dog on the show it's a
great opportunity for me to provide
something more of a personal imprint
than then I provide calling the fight
and setting up Max Kellerman Roy Jones
Andre Ward whoever is working with me as
an expert commentator because as you
know rich play-by-play is essentially a
mechanical role compared to expert
commentary which is more of an
interpretive role I wouldn't say you're
mechanical I mean you certainly give
your two cents that's partly because
boxing is such a subjective sport and
the kind of call we deliver is more
impressionistic than for instance using
something that's statistically based
when I was calling NFL football games
the primary task was to say second and
nine 13 minutes and 10 seconds remaining
in the quarter and set up the expert
commentator to do the replay but in
boxing there are many situations where
I'll provide what amounts to an expert
comment during the course of a round and
Max or Roy might deliver what amounts to
a blow-by-blow type comment if it's
necessary within the flow of what
they're doing so it's a far more
impressionistic kind of a call what's
the most memorable NFL game he called
Jim there were there were quite a number
of them but the most memorable
game in context of history because it's
been shown on the NFL Channel and
various other outlets many times is that
I was calling a game between the Green
Bay Packers and the Cincinnati Bengals
the day that Don Makowski broke his
collarbone and Brett Favre took the
field for the first time and I had had a
conversation with Ron wolf the day
before talking about why would he have
traded a number one draft choice to the
Falcons to get a guy whom the Falcons
had drafted in the third round Brett
Favre and Wolff was candid enough to say
to me said I honestly believe this the
minute Mackowski has to come out of a
game and Brett replaces him on the field
Don
cows key will never be our starter again
and that was a highly prophetic
statement following day mikowski broke
his collarbone on a Tim Crum right
tackle I believe in the third quarter
Brett came onto the field threw a
touchdown pass to a guy named Kittredge
Taylor who never again caught another
touchdown pass in his NFL career won the
game for the Packers and that began his
streak of whatever it was 200 some odd
consecutive starts out there court if
I'm not mistaken though Favre's first
completion was to himself I think was a
batted pass that went back into he's
probably batted by Tim Crum Ronnie so
you had a habit of doing that kind of
thing you call Brett Favre's first snap
as a packer essentially I you know he
hadn't done much with the Falcons I'm
not sure he had ever actually gotten
onto the field with the Falcon I don't
think Jerry Glanville wanted any him
have any part of the field that was an
interesting times for far right back it
back there with the cowboy boots
so was your last one for you who was
your play ball who was the analyst that
you did well I had a lot of different
analysts but I believe the day of that
game I was working with a mod Rashad and
a mod and I used to have a tremendous
time calling games because often we had
a tail end or close to tail in game and
sometimes they would get out of hand and
I would just simply set a mod up and let
him go and I mean he had some amazing
dissertations including how to stay warm
on a Viking sideline without blood grant
seeing you staying warm and and various
other riffs of that nature Ahmad was a
tremendous expert commentator to work
with me I could talk with you forever
Jim please come back please come back
I'll come back forever I appreciate you
I appreciate that the fight game with
Jim Lampley next episode airing
Wednesday at 11 p.m. on HBO and of
course get Canelo Alvarez versus triple
G number two on September the 15th on
HBO pay-per-view good to see you Jim Lee
thank you very much rich the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience